du côté de magny les hameaux peut être
trois listes en lice pour ces élections
municipales bonsoir dominique gradins
bonsoir vous avez été conseiller
municipal de la commune entre 1995 et
2001 dans la majorité de l'ancien maire
jacques los dioses vous êtes en train de
constituer une liste qui s'appelle manie
le bon sens pourquoi vous lancer dans
cette campagne des municipales
et bien en fait donc j'ai été conseiller
municipal de 95 à 2001 et puis en 2001
bon je ne suis pas représenter une
personne nommée non plus demandé de
repartir ce je suis en fait un électron
libre
c'est à dire que je dis un peu ce que je
pense et donc mais ça s'est très bien
passé en fait non je me suis endormi en
toute confiance avec donc le maire
jacques l'oeil aux qui avait fait des
choses intéressantes importante et il
avait fait notamment le domaine du mes
rentes et le la réhabilitation complète
et je me suis dit que ça allait être la
même chose avec le maire actuel
mais en décembre je me suis réveillé un
peu en sursaut en voyant que la ferme de
gomberville qui était en fait une
pépinière doublé d'un centre équestre et
bien que ce tout cet ensemble qui avait
été présenté par l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines allaient être
livrés un promoteur et en faire car tout
cas c'est aussi ce qui se passe sur la
ferme depuis loyal or elle ne sera fait
finalement pas vendu par l'agglomération
de 50 ans ni lui même qui l'a confirmé
il ya notamment un projet de
pérennisation agricole de formation et
de tourisme et d'insertion qui est en
cours ça c'est pas suffisant a en fait
ils à ces choses là apparemment ont été
annoncés il ya très peu de temps parce
qu'en fait moi quand j'en ai parlé
c'était encore rien n'était fait c'est à
dire que depuis trois ans les terres
sont en friche il y a quatre hectares et
demi donc ça pouvait accueillir deux
maraîchers et puis également tous les
locaux qui sont en fait les anciens
locaux de l'opéra de l'établissement
public d'aménagement de saint quentin en
yvelines qui seront à l'abandon depuis
trois ans donc de payer par des choses
plus plus vite peut-être qu'il fallait
faire en fait des choses beaucoup plus
vite surtout qu'avant il y avait les
jardins de cocagne qui était dessus les
jardins de cocagne ont eu des problèmes
et son parti mais rien n'a été fait non
plus pour les pérenniser pour les garder
donc ce qui a été fait c'est de faire ce
qui s'appelle une ferme périurbaines qui
a coûté quand même huit cent mille euros
au niveau de la commune et cette ferme
périurbaines sert à très peu de
personnes parce qu'en fait à l'accueil
de maraîchers actuellement l'un pour
alimenter une amap sur magny les hameaux
d'une centaine d'adhérents et l'autre
maraîchers une amap de guyancourt donc
les hemani quoi paix en fait des choses
fortement alors que ce repas dû être le
camp sur votre liste parlons vent juste
la constitution de votre liste qui je le
précise ce sera sans étiquette où en
êtes-vous est ce que vous êtes non
encore des ventes neuf noms minimum
qu'il faut pour se présenta manière je
suis direct un jeu je dis vraiment ce
que je pense ce que je fais
donc effectivement j'en suis encore loin
pourquoi parce que les gens j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont peur de venir
[Musique]
par rapport à leurs voisins par rapport
à leurs amis de dire bien la liste je
quitte en fait aussi bien une missive de
gauche c'est à dire non et de listo
opposés vont être sans étiquette mais en
fait l'une est une liste de gauche et
l'autre la liste de droite qui était
donc le maire forte en génération
bertrand oignons et l'autre côté le
conseil municipal d'opposition et lionel
lindemann c'est ça tout à fait donc ça
va deux listes une de gauche mais la
gauche un peu plus radicale 1 avec la
france insoumise et génération le pc ne
va quasiment plus être représenté le ps
je ne sais pas et de l'autre côté c'est
la droite avec en marche alors le
programme il en cours de constitution il
nous reste environ 3 minutes dans cet
entretien l'idée forte en tout cas ce
que vous voulez défendre c'est la
démocratie participative mettre en place
notamment des comités participatif et et
consultatif comment ça pourrait
fonctionner en fait en s'inspirant
beaucoup de ce qui se fait aux molières
la ville des molières le maire
département de l'essonne département de
l'essonne mais qui juste à côté de magny
les hameaux
a lancé cette démocratie participative
depuis déjà un ou deux mandats et ça
marche très très bien
à tel point qu'il a créé ce qui
s'appelle aussi des communes et des
citoyens une association qui regroupe
sur toute la france a des gens qui
veulent faire justement cette démocratie
participative
il ya aussi notre idée c'est la
transparence et laissant une
transparence c'est-à-dire que moi je
pense qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
transparence actuellement à la mairie à
la ville de magny les hameaux et je
pense il faudrait une transparence
notamment pour avoir les subventions de
toutes les associations à savoir les
coûts exacts de tous de cette ferme
périurbaines et y'a pas que la ferme
périurbaines il y a également le plateau
de chemin cours qui a été réaménagé en
faisant trois trous de golf et le golf
il faut savoir que le golf national et
sur la commune donc pourquoi aller créer
3 3 que les gi en cours aussi notamment
sa cheval ans on va dire sur les deux
communes où et sur l'île est localisé
sur la commune de guyancourt
juste un mot parce que c'est important
il ya une double identité à magny les
hameaux de la commune qui est aussi bien
membre du parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse et de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout comment
elle doit se positionner justement avec
109 être ça s'était très bien positionné
jusqu'à présent c'est-à-dire en fait je
clos lloze avait lancé l'idée que magny
les hameaux et est une petite ville à la
campagne et ça se passait très bien mais
maintenant en fait la petite ville
eh bien elle fait un petit peu n'importe
quoi et puis la campagne depuis que j'ai
reparlé d'agricole eh bien on commence à
revenir un petit peu à dire la ferme de
gomberville la ferme de bulles loyer on
va faire de l'agricole mais c'est pas
maintenant c'était avant qu'il fallait y
penser
dernière chose est-ce que vous avez des
rendez vous de prévu des réunions pour
présenter le projet aux habitants
manicouagan oui alors j'ai une rang
un rendez vous ce samedi à la salle
madeleine landais et puis au village
donc au restaurant scolaire
rosa bonheur au village de manille les
ont retrouvés l'ensemble des agents
d'adp campagne un des candidats aux
municipales sur notre site internet tv
78 points comme merci dominique grappin
est d'être venu parler de votre
candidature manie le bon sens vous êtes
donc potentiel troisième candidat pour
le scrutin des municipales
et je précise que sont engagés également
dans la campagne à magny les hameaux le
maire sortant bertrand ou lyon et le
conseiller municipal d'opposition lionel
l'île de man